[Music]
braden's in memphis hi brayden how are
you
hey dave hey anthony how you doing great
man how can we help
so got a quick question for you um i'm
21 years old i have
60 000 cash saved up um i have a 8 000
emergency fund and me and my wife
have we've been married for almost three
years now we've been renting the house
for my dad
for about two years now and
he's offered to sell it to us for a
pretty generous
um amount that he was willing to give it
to us for so it's just a praise
for about 215 to 220 and he's once saw
it to us for 140.
excellent and um i was just wondering am
i in the position to go on and do that
my only concern is that it is an older
house it's been in our family for
70 years now and so it is older but it's
in really good shape um
is that something smart that i should do
or should i hold off and keep renting
braden how much what's your household
income right now
so household income is about 55 to 60
000.
okay 55 to 60 000. and um
you have no other debt no debt good for
you
well done you guys got started early and
you did well yeah
good good work thank you okay everything
here sounds fine on the numbers
uh the only red flag i heard was it's a
family heirloom
what happens when you want to move well
we've already
discussed that and he's perfectly okay
with that i mean there's no
big connection to it it's just it was
his dad's dad's and then got handed down
and he ended up buying it from someone
else that moved into it
um and so he bought it from him so
you're not gonna have some
you're not gonna have your mother mad or
some uncle matt or something like that
no no sir okay they're not going to win
a piece of the uh profit when you sell
it and make that extra hundred thousand
dollars that he missed out on
no sir so when i um i'll take out a 80
000
loan to um you know put after i put my
60 down
and and then it'll be deeded over to me
and that's it
for them i like it then go get it yes i
would do that
i definitely would do that there's
nothing wrong with it at all and here's
the thing if you don't have to live
there forever
sure don't if the thing starts giving
you fits because of its age
make a move later so 10 years from today
your life is going to be way different
than it is right now
yes sir we were actually gifted um a 100
acre farm last year
from my grandpa and so our ideal
situation is to build over there
really what i was wanting to do and
instead of paying rent in this house
would be putting my money into the
equity back into the house that way
when we're ready financially to pay cash
for the house that we want to build on
the
farm then we can sell that house and
just dump it all into the next house
a wonderful plan all right beautiful now
the other
the only other thing is i want your dad
to check with his tax advisor
because he is giving you equity in
excess of
gift tax limits and so he may need to
file a a gift tax
filing with his income tax and if you
can remember this phrase teach him this
phrase a unified
estate tax credit he may want to use
some of his estate
exemption to be able to give you this
gift without paying taxes
otherwise he could get dinged with some
gift tax in the event of an audit
because he gave you a very very large
gift in excess of
uh what is allowed right now without
taxes and so
um you know that that's you know the
whole process so have him have him check
with his
uh tax advisor on that and figure out
exactly what the best plan is to do that
the best way to do it but probably a
unified estate tax credit
is going to be the best direction